皆さん
テレヴィッツマートフォンパーソナルコンピュータニンテンドー3 b フィン程度
スイング a station とうに過ぎていませんか
なんてことな大叶うだめよ
私も含めてるかなざみーん
そんなことをしてイっちゃう
命がメーカー悪くなってしまう
はいというわけでえ主力がすごい落ちました
僕でしずっと編集とばスマホ見てるとほんとに名悪くなりますよ皆さん
目は大切でしょなので今日はそんな女を突かれている僕なんですけども食べ物で目に何
がいいかと思ったときもうこれしかないでしょっていうのはもう言っておりました
パディとテンション高い野心家だからちょっとテンション高くだったりかもしれない
なぁ位グルーベリーです
群馬県のブルー
ベリーをわざわざすごい沢山の良かったんですけどこれ一個どれくらい入ってるんだ
うまそうだなというか目によさそうだなぁっ
110がつくなんで代々100ず10個ぐらいから各塾ぐらい入ってますもう気づけ
でしょ
ちょっと日々の疲れて目がちょっとヤバイんでレベルよなるべく限界まで食べたら
いろいろ知るか戻るんじゃねーかと思ってテレビ僕の視力なんですけどもあそこに書い
てあれ僕の僕の肖像画スラブをとってギリギリもう見えないくらいなんで
恋愛
いける24は2808者
あーけ
結構まぁちょっと少なめに見てに1800粒
ブルベリがありますとりあえずちょっと僕が今食べられる限界の量までブルーベリーを
体に投入して
ば少なくともブルーベリーを止めで目がよくなるんですよ何かしらの割れで多分良く
なるんで全然にちょっと疑問に思ったのがブルーベリー
何つぶったらお腹いっぱいになるかっていうのをちょっと調べて行きたいと思います
全部ブルーベリー
ではなんとかなるっしょまあ一般成人男性が食べれるブルーベリーの限界量ですね
ぜひ何かの参考するように
[音楽]
こうやって一つずつ色ながら謎を解き明かしていくのもユーチューバーの仕事ですから
ウルメリーちょっと全部置いていきます
[音楽]
はいじゃあ検証していこうと思いますいただきますん
ああああああ
可愛いなぁなんか bellevue 食べるってなるかわいいよねをいただきます
[音楽]
でこれ洗わなくていいのかなすごい土の土の味がしたんだけど大丈夫かな
まあ一緒にずどんどん食べてきます
めっちゃうまええこれ多分やばいくれるうん水においしい
て体に良さげ
ん
パイ100校行きましたいやいや
恋しいいやと美脚ことだこれカードに変化はなくが全然まだまだいけそうでちょっと
どんどん振っていきましょう
[音楽]
うん
はい300個食べました
おっ
まだかろうじて美味しいですただやはり300万に行くとちょっとこ体に溜まる感じは
ありつつも
がここで終わったら動画つまんなくなるちょっと頑張ります
ん
うんうん
[音楽]
ん
持って
me
500粒食べましたん
はぁ
はっはっは
最高の感覚でたもんだよ
3投げるぞ
ブルーベリーアイプルプルプルプルプル縁あいあーパパっっ
ん
ああああああ
700個食べましたあーやばいわばいばいばいばいばーいもういいかなって感じですで
もこうね諦められほっとこうだったらいいんじゃ
[音楽]
は
ん
[音楽]
angele
うん
oo まさか戦後食べるとは思っていませんでした
させんあの先にちょっと行っておくんですけどもかなりも限界です
肩が重いなら方々がすごい重くなってきましたらちょっと限界までモード迫ってみよう
と思いますでは
うんうん
うんうんうん
ブルーベリー
副作用もう弱さすげー今更なんですけど急に不安になってブルーベリーの副菜を調べた
んですけど
特にないらしいですよかった
[音楽]
だめだ
心では動けって思ってるけど体が動かない
おっ
水は0
もう
baby baby 第二結果的に精360粒食べましたか
山でます黒じゃなく舌がすごいお腹が痛くなりモスまあこれだけでこれだけじゃ腕に
ブルーベリー取ればバスが2名の方は良くなるはずなるわけねーだろ
me
あっはぁ
やばいブルーベリーどっかいった